i'm
so tired ugh i only slept like five or
six hours and when i'm traveling
that takes a toll on me like last night
i think i slept at like maybe 1 30 or
something
and it didn't feel that late because you
know it's like two hours ahead so it's
only 11 30 back in vegas
but um i try to like you know just take
a hot shower relax
and i guess when you're in a new
environment it's harder to sleep or
something like that but then i gotta
wake up at six i just finished ironing
two of the pants
because even before
um we go and check out the gym we have
to bang out a couple of
shoots on the barbell brigade side
because we're dropping these really dope
tees called legacy tees and it's more
like a casual
elevated look as opposed to like the
more gym-centric stuff which is why i'm
busting out
um the stretch cargo that we launched
earlier this year that was supposed to
go and theme with this
where it's like more casual based but it
also gave me an excuse
to get some shoes yesterday which i'm
really happy these are some uh
air max 90s i forgot they're called
the terrascapes
they're dope it's like all black or like
a shade of black
with that clear bottom so this will pair
really good
wait let me get on this side so you can
see with the skull but this should pair
really good with that shoe
i mean with that pant see
look at that damn and then i got these
um just the classic
uh shell toes like the superstars
you know like back from my junior high
style or at least when i went to junior
high
and they used a pair like these guys all
right super classic and these will look
really good with the uh tan cargos bam
well that's tight it shows up on the gps
alpha land
so we actually had a scheduling mix up
today we're supposed to go do the photo
shoot which is why i uh iron my pants
the name steamed the clothes they were
ready to rock and roll
but then we found out that the dates got
switched so we're actually gonna go meet
up with max first which is cool and get
to check out his operation
and his operation it's in alphaland i
believe so you know that's dope i love
when homies work together because it
kind of reminds me of remember back when
we had the big jk space and like david
had office in there too yeah yeah that
was super cool
[Music]
oh this is tight this is the entrance
damn
you know i like branding
i like that
learn more
be more
wow this place is huge
there's about like three buildings here
at least you don't have to pay for
parking there's like 10 buildings
there's 10 buildings three gyms
damn
there's that many people here already
that's dope like later i came yesterday
like later in the day yeah and they're
like it was packed like all the parking
yeah and they're like oh thank god you
got here before the rush i was like oh
[ __ ] damn that's awesome most of people
park
yeah this would almost be impossible to
build in l.a to even have parking like
this look at this it would literally be
impossible that's sick
dang look at that big ass sign
oh man you know you made it
when you got a fountain in the front
look at that
that's baller
all right so the two gyms are over there
but we need to meet at the offices
three gyms
the game was here yesterday already so
it worked out so you got a little sneak
peek oh this is where all the offices
are that's dope alphalete
head cortez
hey what's up dude how are you doing how
are you i know man
yeah it got all confusing because yeah
geo kept saying like saturday morning on
saturday morning
where are they that's when i listen to
the sheep instead of 4 10.
honestly she's really irresponsible
that's right yeah she's really really
irresponsible i don't really like her
she's up really early she's gone oh
you're in vegas now yeah she's up early
just to like [ __ ] up other stuff but she
literally goes in like our company like
program thing and just tells wrong dates
yeah just deleting files and words
yeah i hate her man he will come
and then
like one
step further is our scholarship
distribution center so that's where we
all were
so then we over over here so this is
like the corporate so charlie is on the
literally the opposite corner of the
building
right outside the gym right
no it's like it's like the back back
corner like you can't even see it from
here it's it's like all the way if you
went straight that way
over there he makes all the noise behind
the second channel does he make all the
noise that's why he has to be somewhere
far away
no that's just how he got set up
he's actually probably quieter than i am
but are you guys like the three best
amigos
how did you guys like become so tight
because you guys weren't necessarily
like so tight in the beginning of like
the youtube fitness space right i don't
know i guess christian and shawley have
they gonna play back in like high school
that's true that's true basketball
together they were make friends then and
then they went to high school together
yeah i don't think they were super close
then yeah um and then you know i started
i met christian in 2014 at the arnold
we became really good friends and i came
here and met charlie through christian
yeah and they were like kind of like
they were like not as close they are now
yeah yeah and then just
there's
yeah they just started working out and
they just got closer yeah cuz like a lot
of people here like
christian charlie our other friend joe
like they literally grew up here they're
the type of people that like they went
to middle school here and they're gonna
like build their house here yeah yeah
yeah whereas i'm like i want to get out
of where i like yeah yeah yeah everyone
here like sugarland they're like i don't
even leave it's so cool that you guys
are like three moguls and three best
buddies i'm trying on here man it's it's
dope it's crushing it
dude i thought you were a millionaire
dude i know i thought i was supposed to
have a lambo or something
now whenever i like
someone used to be when someone pissed
me off on the highway or something i
could like be cool like floor past them
yeah i like smash it my rpms go up and
i'm just like
did you have like a you had a srt8
before and this one's like a mom's
soccer mom car now it is
dude you're getting old we're waiting
for the new one dude it'll be fine oh
all right
i don't know if i could be seen in this
man
i got a reputation uphold
i think our car is worse than i know it
is it is that boy though this is no this
is that that's a really good car
so i'm in max's warehouse right now and
it's so small it's actually way smaller
than you see online and i don't even
know how he like really survives even
because he's only sending out maybe like
i don't know like five bags a day which
is freaking crazy
yeah his warehouse is so small look he
only has these ones and then he only has
those and this and then he only has that
over there and he only has like those
it's just like with most things it's
it's much bigger
or smaller in real life no i'm just
kidding no this is this is amazing this
is freaking cool
i just need one more shot of you guys
are you kidding me was you guys talking
and i want to get a shot of like the
warehouse while you guys are so act like
the interview was right there why are
you always bossing us around
runs the show that's true now he's good
right here
what is that a dip bar for
young people
it's a dip bar for our kids just act
like you guys are talking to them and
grab shops
all right so this is the second time max
locked himself out just this morning we
were at your microphone thing it makes
me think we were in alpha land and then
he
we were in alpha land and he locked
himself out and we just came here and he
walked out and this thing automatically
locks
see
this is funny because even big ceos are
careless
yeah it's gonna be funny until we no one
can come open the door for us we can't
go anywhere i know
operations manager yeah blame it on that
guy
not good yeah what are you doing on a
saturday how come we're not at work
let's see let me call
who's
so what do you think he's a big old boss
but
you can't even keep track of his keys do
you remember when we used to live
together and every day i would have to
climb through the window
yeah
i feel like i don't have anything to say
then i can i don't know that means
you're gonna be a future giant ceo dude
it's the same quality traits
haha la sega you thought oil and gas was
the right business to get into huh
you're out of business should have
gotten into candies
he's like that's right
that's because they outgrew this fight
oh yeah that's true
yeah you see this this is what i was
expecting
like a rolls royce ferrari what is that
a mercedes uh
gt amg
that's what i was
expecting damn what kind of day is this
all right so nadeem's food came out
first what did you get sandwich uh this
was a roti sandwich and then grits just
because i got breakfast spots like you
like grits
uh they're pretty good no i've only had
them in like california yeah uh and i've
heard like great things about like we're
kind of in like a southern state right
yeah so it's like oh it's like what
they're known for i know about this
restaurant it looks good though the big
old melted butter on top yeah other
places wouldn't even ask you for that so
yeah that's like another step and then
just a roast recipe i'm not a breakfast
food person so
how come oh you don't like the sweet
stuff
i like i love sweets but like i feel
like for breakfast or like food like
savory i like savory
i saw this million dollar bacon on the
menu on my million dollar bacon what is
that all about this looks crazy good
all right let's have a taste of this
million dollar bacon
you put maple syrup on there
a little bit of chives i think oh it's a
little spicy too black pepper
this is really good
i never had bacon
but maple syrup and pepper
if you could eat
bacon i would say you should try this
one one day
so the dean just took a bite
and he moaned
it's not good
yeah usually
most places are just like whatever yeah
it's like a really like known restaurant
yeah
but
the bread is like
really crunchy and
soft it's like sun-dried tomatoes i
think it's like
spinach and the roast beef is so well
oh here's my food
look at that
oh i'm good thank you oh it's all crispy
too
egg and a
little chode
[Music]
that's a juicy sausage
really good
i keep seeing you put butter on this
really good horseradish
all right so i devoured my eggs
and sausage already because i can't wait
to get to this crispy waffle a lot of
times waffles don't come out crispy
because just by sitting there it gets
soft but i'm gonna pour this preserve on
there
[Music]
oh yeah
perfect
perfect
you eat like a pizza
[Music]
really good
so fluffy too
all right just finished grabbing food
time to train that's why i got a light
breakfast or else i want to stuff myself
but i know it's time to train i'm
actually excited to check out the gym so
i have a little sneak peek before
i um give the tour on the barber brigade
channel but it's going to be cool
because i'm going to train for reals and
the dean's going to shoot a training
video so catch you guys in there
wow
look at that whoa
it's a big store i like the lights
right here look
oh what
yeah they ain't messing around huh
holy moly
that's dope
that's really cool
wow
i'm glad they have water because i was
getting kind of thirsty what is that oh
come on that's so unprofessional dude
wait til aaron sees that isn't he
getting so mad do you need to tell them
what is that dude
[Music]
i'm gonna put one star on yelp hanging
wires
this is dangerous i know so david almost
got electrocuted here
finish the workout
i actually lost my belt i think in the
bathroom but it was a blessing in
disguise because i got to hit a heavy
single on deadlift and heavy single on
squats which i've been curious what the
beltless version of those were so i'll
post the video right here now i'm at
alpha eats where i'm gonna grab a
protein shake and then meet up with
christian
let's see
huh all right so it's my first time here
what smoothie should i get what's the
best one it's my first and last time the
peanut butter blueberry banana can i get
the peanut butter blueberry bananas
anything else
nah that'd be off
i'll have that ready for you all right
thank you
you know what i'm tired of i'm tired of
these big shot people all the time like
literally i was talking to christian
right and then he has these hired actors
that are like big fans of his and they
come and they take these pretend
pictures just so he can be out of the
conversation it's so annoying i'm like
dude i've known you for such a long time
why do you have to hire people i'm gonna
talk to them right after watch
hey christian how come you always have
all these like hired actors to like
pretend like you're familiar
yeah i already know you're famous why do
you gotta pretend to be so famous for it
i'm trying to impress you man okay well
i'm pretty impressed look at that just
because camera's not even on dude just
pretend like he's doing stuff
dude i know i know i know your tricks
dang tricks dude and you're gonna
capture all these tricks all right
what is this a secret passageway
wow
only christian knows a secret passageway
that's crazy
okay you're not gonna go the secret
passageway i'll give a secret in one
minute okay
he probably has diarrhea
no i think he has diarrhea
all right so we're about to do our photo
shoot
all right so we're about to do our photo
shoot for our brand new legacy
collection out here in downtown houston
so these are the shirts that we're
dropping it's more of an elevated more
clean mature look you can wear it out in
casual and not so like gym and graphic
focused so i'm carrying these two shirts
with the stretch cargos that we dropped
not too long ago
and these super clean white shoes i was
showing you guys earlier and this will
be with like the zipper uh zipped open
so it covers the shoe
with this one with the
with the stretch green cargo i'm pairing
it with these new shoes that i just got
i feel like it looks pretty cool
together and then i'll wear it with the
bottoms tucked in so it can show like a
different look but if you're looking for
some barbell brigade gear that's a
little bit more like mature looking you
know go out to the bar and grab a
bite to eat and a drink then stay tuned
for the legacy collection because
it's dope
bam
it looks clean right
so you have to be like hey do you want
to go on a date
and they usually say yes if you're
rocking something clean like this what
do you think that looks good that's
great
thank you the model could do some work
but
i know do i'm around in certain places
but that's why i get like a size a
little bit bigger so kind of like what
do the kids call the pump covers home
covers
what about from the side does it look i
don't look as brown right no you
actually your arms are big and then your
chest sticks out so it's cool thank you
but from this thing we kind of look like
a like a gangbanger a gang finger yeah a
gang bang cargo pants yeah what do you
mean
gangbangers don't wear no cargo pads
yeah those look like uh what are those
white shoes that they wear are the
cortezers
it looks good they look good uh that's
true they do look very well put together
thank you
all right
so i swapped pants and shoes
and now i'm wearing it tucked in like
this
to see my ankles and the bottoms are
more tapered in and i'm wearing the
black one now so if you're interested in
this shirt
um it's a 30s single which means it's
really light really thin really
comfortable just kind of just floats and
hangs on you so it's super comfortable
and that's why it looks so good
like in a more casual setting versus
more thicker beefier more streetwear
based teeth this is for sure more of
like that more mature more elegant look
and now i'm ready to go
now i look like a japanese photographer
where'd you get that from
i don't know i feel like those guys are
really stylish oh
not the old school ones like my dad's
age but the new and you they got like
the cool brim glasses and like cool hats
and stuff
how do i look
look good thank you very much
back in the hotel had a pretty
productive successful day i believe
able to meet up with some old friends
shoot really cool videos with a borrow
brigade channel
got a quick photo shoot in
now i'm going to
take a hot shower
and relax
and then
get some good night's sleep
um and i'm glad we banged out the photo
shoot today because it was supposed to
be for tomorrow morning but now that we
finished it then tomorrow morning uh
like you could sleep in a little bit
which will be good because i'm still
kind of backed up on sleep because last
night i'm trying to sleep here
but
oh we slept late and then earlier
i was gonna try to take a nap but the
people kept banging on the walls and
stuff so it was just so hard so i'm kind
of backed up a little bit
so after tomorrow i should be good but
thank you guys for following and i'll
see you guys oh my god you guys see me
just scratching my ass
i was talking to you like this i was
like scratching my ass alright good
night everybody